[Music]
my name is Dominic Morano where 27
French treat ak4 interview pizza my
father owns a store his name is Frank
Morano usually doesn't come here that
much anymore that's what he got me for
my father Frank he grew up on Sicilian
he loves the corners crispy you get that
good sauce you get the good cheese and
it's just it's just so much flavor in it
I think it's the iconic pizza because
you can't really find anywhere do you
know anywhere else that you can find a
Sicilian pepperoni like this with that
kind of pepperoni in that type of slice
I can't really make this a clean is
first we've got the guys innovation
making all the dough please service have
some measurements are inside the secret
ingredients
and we let it chill overnight and then
we bring it back upstairs we get a
cast-iron pan we use olive oil slather
it up nice and good scrape the doze off
you press it down you let it rise a
little bit because if it doesn't rise
enough you won't get that fluffy flavor
and that tankiness and put the fresh
looked at on we put the Fra Diavolo
sauce with the pepperonis and pop it in
the oven for about 10 minutes and then
in gold I've ever want to buy from our
food distributors it's a special cut a
tiny pepperoni it's a stick and we cut
about maybe 15 to 20 bucks today that
type of pepperoni it curls up and the
oil which is extra virgin olive oil sits
in the cup no people think it's grease
and it's not an egg on against me
offended masu by Danielle supply stood
still greasy so it's not very seed it's
olive oil is good for you I promise you
that I want people think at the big
roast gigantic slice and also be greased
rather in the mouth in it
[Music]
this all started it was my fault Olivia
I gave all the credits on my father I
can't say I'm just the present here he
was trying to figure out something
that's not biased to people that
everybody so what is something that
generally everybody in the world people
you can't go wrong with it I love it
when I meet celebrities I love wanna
meet Ashley but people that come here
every day are regulars that come here on
that lunch break that want to stand up
and I'm lined 100 degree pizzeria
eat a hot slice and they still enjoy it
there's no better join Center I get so
much happiness and joy when I see people
coming in and they say it's the best
life that every never like I have to
pity old people for young people is the
best life they've ever even forty years
my five year old mill pizzeria is making
them think that this is the best life
that they've ever eaten and it just
fills me up inside like I can't describe
this feeling